I really excited anytime we got new nipy
coming n for sure I know last time uh
when you came on the show you had uh
dropped tidbits that may or may not have
gotten you in trouble about there being
a nipsy Hustle N it didn't get me in
trouble but that [__] hit the blog that
dude it everywhere and and then I was
just only and then there was people who
were like yeah right he's lying like bro
like if he anybody would know it might
be him like yeah you feel me like come
on man like and then all I said was like
bro got so much music like I'm pretty
sure it's for sure going to be another
nip album is there an update there I
mean [__] what you think bro you don't
think it's going to be another has to be
another nip Al come on man cuz like you
said you he has so much unreleased music
it just has to be done the right way
that's the only thing is like yeah it
ain't going to get put out just cuz cuz
you because you know what right cuz I
almost think like when Pac passed there
was like a couple of them albums that
were rough but the first like one or two
do you remember me and then um the one
that had uh the the the the acoustic uh
thugs mansion on it was hard oh uh which
which one was it better better better
days was fire yeah better days has some
[__] but then there was like the [__]
that like he was working with like
artists he would have never have worked
with when he was alive yeah bro like um
what was that uh he had like a song with
Eminem and uh bro Eminem did the whole
album BR he produced
he and did
because you bro you had to get used to
hearing Pac on Eminem beat it was more
like some mashup like [__] yeah that's
right it was that's that's that's all it
was you know what I mean like I'm a Pac
fan I'm an mem fan you know what I mean
but to hear Pac on the Eminem beat bro
it just kind of it wasn't I wasn't ready
I wasn't ready for it it was it was a
little weird for sure it'd be like if it
would have been dope if like some of the
OG producers Pac was working with
came and took some of those stems yeah
curated something like did it the right
Dazz in to do some production you know
what I'm saying that's the right way to
do it Superfly bring DH Superfly in
there you feel me should maybe Dre yeah
you feel me and then yeah Dre can do the
mixing even quick too call Quick in you
feel me quick G come on man quick could
have did that whole album that would
have been crazy and it would have been
more it would have been more like uh you
know it would have sounded like a Tupac
album n it definitely would have sound
but quick and uh
crazy for sure man yo it's crazy too
like obviously you're a big poac fan th
life
too uh it's kind of crazy to see there's
finally like all these years later
someone got arrested for his death
what's that Tupac's death man that [__]
crazy bro and then we still don't even
know yeah we still don't even know what
to believe man you know what me I mean
and that's the thing is like it feels I
mean look as like a fan I mean you don't
want to ever see anybody go to jail yeah
yeah but like but why but why so long
though like thing is that this that's
why that's that's what seemed tricky is
like you've been hearing the same story
all along all along all along like why
y'all wait 30 years this guy was doing
all these interviews and he been doing
interviews they eventually I think I
think he's done so many interviews that
it had to have finally like come across
like bro yeah your time Las Vegas Metro
like like radar where they're like wait
this guy's wait what like we should go
see if this cuz
cuz I I always tell people like the
Tupac they probably pinched him you know
what I mean just
to get some more just to get some more
information right and and to me the
Tupac and Biggie murders are very
different like the Tupac murder was some
retaliation [__] that really wasn't
didn't have it was some Street [__] that
that popped off in one night as opposed
to like the biggie [__] was like a hit
and depending on who you listen to like
the LAPD off duty cops might have been
involved like I don't think the LAPD
wanted to solve the biggie murder
because it would have made them look
crazy the Tupac murder was just
like you know Orlando Anderson died and
that was who everybody was saying it was
the you know the guy behind it so this
dude's been doing all these interviews
[__] got to stop self snitching
bro yeah this [__] crazy bro like people
just just just just people will
literally snitch on themselves just for
the views man for real it's crazy you se
you seen that interview with no jumper
when he asked uh yeah ask for that
question
said he's like all right so I mean you
know he didn't know how to handle it
after that he yeah he he was supposed to
come on the show uh earlier this morning
but um we
rescheduled I didn't know cuz he I
didn't know I had him come early cuz I
don't I don't know La politics I don't
know if you guys get along I don't know
n it's all good you feel me no but you
know I I don't know if if I ever have
two La rappers in the same day spre
[__] the Earth is my turf I love that
you know what I mean I go anywhere I
walk anywhere if I run it or whoever
it's going to be what it's going to be
if it's respect it respect if it ain't
it ain't you know what I mean that clip
uh was very funny though you see that
clip yeah X4 was just like Adam asked
him if he was involved in some shootout
on video and he just looked at him like
this yeah I like damn and I think you've
shown like um I gave you props last time
like when you and trell did that
interview on no jumper that was like a
big deal yeah for sure I went I went out
of town I somewhere out of town and I
ran into one of his homies and [__] he
like yeah man I'm from hu man I seen
that video you did with my homie you
feel me no I just think that [__] should
be like an example for the Young
Generation so you see like the the the
difference in a respect level you feel
me like yeah I think like cuz I told him
I'm like you know [__] either
going to hate it or love it he like both
yeah he like they going to hate it or
they going to love it you know what I
mean like it is what it is but so what
you feel me yeah I just think it's like
it's it's important to be able to show
people like you know we can break the
cycle and some of my homies knew who he
was like when I let the homies know like
you feel me like they knew who he was
you I mean show shout out to T yeah man
you know great guy salute um so next
year for sure 12 albums for sure already
already put it see one thing about me
once I put out out all right so I got my
January album ready okay so that's ready
mix and master ready so we're going from
November 22nd to the January album
straight into the January album damn you
ain't playing yeah and I thought about
I'm like damn I need to give you know
success some time to breathe you feel me
tour some shows and all that but like
you know with the game right now bro the
year is it's going to be a new year yeah
music industry kind of resets for people
who don't know that's what I'm saying so
it's really all on like who going who
going who going to go to heart as soon
as the bar drop so that's why I say when
the bar drop I drop feel me January 1st
oh that's that's when the Al's dropping
yeah oh [__] okay right away right away
bro no I ain't giving nobody no room bro
no breathing room bro I'm not playing I
love it yeah 258 no brace for real man
in the flesh I love it man for you have
you um obviously nip uh you guys just
did a uh a dope show was it at the Roxy
you guys all did uh the the was it Roxy
or L is a little bit more bigger than
the Roxy I was it was either Roxy or L
we was going to originally do it at the
Roxy but would have been too small
exactly we need we needed a little bit
more expansion but obviously he was so
good at like curating artists bringing
you know artists on to the to the team
is that something you want to do as well
put the co hat on eventually and
definitely sign tent um for sure you
know like I said you know when when the
when the when the year drop I'm also
going to announce you know what I mean a
couple of my artists oh so you've
already done I've been doing music with
yeah cuz you know they they going to
drop too
and is that a is that 258 it's 258 yeah
no breaks for sure so I got I got a good
I got I got some good management going
on some marketing you feel me
PRS yeah we locked in man feel me I'm to
take this label [__] to another level
yeah you had to have learned so much too
just being around everybody you've been
around to where you can kind of like
apply so much of the game that you've
gotten over the years yeah you got to
think about it like we grew up we grew
up we grew up watching
you know the Masterpiece you know what I
mean the the the uh the easy EAS the sh
kns the Jermaine the pr you feel what
I'm saying like they had a CEO mentality
you feel what I'm saying that's why I
just did the uh the soundtrack for the
movie Bon P I just saw that yeah exactly
so you know I grew up you know death row
all the soundtracks what Above the Rim
Minister Society come on bro I don't
even know what's going on with
soundtracks anymore cuz the soundtracks
back in the day that's what I'm saying
so I'm trying to bring that back you
feel me like we got a good La movie
going on all right let me put some la
music behind it you feel me let me make
the soundtrack for it let me grab some
artist from here from there make a yeah
Cate a whole soundtrack n that's dope I
mean [__] the last time someone did that
and killed it I think was black panther
black panther K killed that man shout
out that was a good album had s SOB on
there oh yeah Mazy was on there Mazy was
on there I'm like oh yeah we looking
good yes and that was like 2 17 or 18 to
like so like it was I was like finally
mazy's getting like a look and that was
like that was like it wasn't a Kendrick
Lamar album but that was like it was
about as much when he didn't put out an
album you had to be like all right that
was it was kind of like Eminem Z mile it
was like it was kind of like m& this
about as close to Eminem albums you can
get like Kendrick's fingerprints all
over the album that a Mile soundtrack
was crazy boy